[موسيقى]
40 عاما مرت على ذكرى قرارات الرئيس
السوداني الراحل جعفر النميري بتطبيق
قوانين سبتمبر عام 1983 وهي القوانين التي
قام بموجبها باعلان تطبيق الشريعه
الاسلاميه ومنها القوانين الجنائيه او ما
يعرف بالحدود الشرعيه بتطبيق حد السرقه
بقطع اليد اليمنى وتطبيق حد الحرابه بقطع
اليد اليمنى مع القدم اليسرى وكذلك حد
الزنااء الرجيم والجلد حدا لشاربي الخمور
والقتل بتهمه الرده بالاضافه الى قانون
الامر بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر في 24
اكتوبر 1983 صدر اول حكم بالقطع وقالت
وكاله السودان للانباء ان محكمه قضت بقطع
اليد اليمنى والرجل اليسرى لاحد الاشخاص
بعد ادانته بالسطو على محل للادوات
الكهربائيه والكاميرات في الخرطوم وقضت
محكمه اخرى بقطع يد احد اللصوص وفي العام
الى مسيره مليونيه احتفالا بالذكرى الاولى
للاعلان عن تطبيق الشريعه نظمها حسن
الترابي زعيم الحركه الاسلاميه في السودان
دعا اليها عددا من رموز وقيادات الحركه
الاسلاميه من بينهم يوسف القرضاوي ومحمد
والشيخ محمد الغزالي وصلاح ابو اسماعيل
لمنح التجربه قوه شعبيه وجماهيريه
عكس سبتمبر محطات مختلفه فبعد تولي الصادق
المهدي الحكم عقب انهيار حكم النميري عام
1985 ساعه الى تجميد تلك القوانين الا ان
الجبهه القوميه الاسلاميه بزعامه حسن
الترابي تمسكت بتلك القوانين في العام
1989 انقلبت الجبهه الاسلاميه القوميه على
الحكومه الائتلافيه التي تراسها المهدي
واتخذت العميد وقتها عمر البشير زعيمه
للانقلاب والقائد الفعلي هو حسن الترابي
واصدر قانون الجنائي للعام 1991 متضمن
للماده 126 والتي تنص على تطبيق حد الرده
عقوبه لكل من يروج للخروج من مله الاسلام
في العام 2005 توصلت قياده الجبهه القوميه
الاسلاميه الى اتفاق سلام مع الحركه
الشعبيه في جنوب السودان ذات الاغلبيه
المسيحيه بقياده جون جارينك نص الاتفاق
على الاحتفاظ بالشريعه الاسلاميه في شمال
السودان مقابل اعفاء الجنوبي منها منذ
العام 1983 وحتى اليوم لا زالت تطالعنا
الصحف السودانيه الرسميه والغير رسميه من
وقت لاخر عن تنفيذ عمليه تطبيق حد السرقه
او الحرابه اخرها ما نشرته وسائل الاعلام
اجنبيه وسودانيه غير رسميه منذ عده ايام
اصدار محكمه الفتح بام درمان حكما بقطع
اليد لثلاثه شباب بتهمه سرقه انابيب الغاز
فما قصه قانون تطبيق الشريعه في السودان
وما هي محطاته ومن ساهم في صياغته وتنفيذه
انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعات
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع يشارك معنا السياسي
السوداني المخضرم المحبوب عبد السلام وهو
احد المقربين من حسن ترابي زعيم الحركه
الاسلاميه في السودان قبل ان يطالبه
باعتزال السياسه ودعم الحركه الاسلاميه
ووصولها الى الحكم قبل ان يغير رايه تماما
حياك الله معنا استاذ مرحبا بكم
اسمح لي ابدا معك استاذ محبوب واسالك
بدايه
شو السياقات التي ظهرت معها قوانين
سبتمبر التي عرفت قوانين بقوانين سبتمبر
يعني قبل صدورها في العام 1983
لان السودان بعد خروج البريطانيين في
العام 56 ونحو منتصف العقد الستين كانت
غالب قوانينه موروثه من البريطانيين وكانت
تعاني اختلالات في المضمون وكذلك تعاني
اختلالات حتى في وجود
النص الذي يمكن ان يستند اليه القضاه
والمحامون في اصدار الاحكام
فنشات في منتصف الستينات لجان
لتاسيس قانون سوداني واستمرت هذه اللجان
عقب
سيطره
اليسار ثم تحولا النميري بعد ذلك فكان
هنالك سي السوداني لاصلاح القانون وتاسيس
سبق قانوني سوداني بالتمام
وتعاقب على تنفيذ هذا الامر جماعات من
القانونين السودانيين السودان والحصن الحظ
في ذلك الوقت كان يتوفر على اسماء قانونيه
كبيره جدا وعميقه جدا في معرفتها بالقانون
وكان ارثا السودان مع البريطانيين ايضا
جيدا ومتميزا ولكن ينبغي ان يكون هنالك
قانون سوداني يستلهم تاريخ الشعب وثقافته
ومن ذلك الشريعه الاسلاميه
فاستمر هذا الجهد القانوني المهم عبر اربع
وزراء للعدل
زكي مصطفى
وزكي عبد الرحمن
وحسن عمر
والرشيد الطاهر وحسن الترابي كل هؤلاء
اقاموا المجهود كبير جدا حتى يكون هنالك
ثبت قانوني سوداني جيد بعد المصالحه
الوطنيه في 77 كذلك قامت لجنه تسمى لجنه
مراجعه القوانين لتتماشى مع الشريعه
الاسلاميه وهذه اللجنه راس جانبها الفني
الدكتور الترابي الذي اعلن ان 10% فقط
قوانين السودان لا تتماشى مع الشريعه
الاسلاميه واغلبها عارض عابر مثلا قانون
الجمارك ينص على ضريبه للخمر لان القانون
السودان لم يكن يحرم الخمر بهذا المعنى
فهذا السياق الذي كان يشرف عليه في الاخير
حسن الترابي والذي تلخص في 11 مجلد طبعت
طباعه فاخره كلفت بمعايير ذلك الوقت
تكاليف كبيره وكان الوضع القانوني في في
اتم الاستقرار واتم التطور واتم التعبير
عن
السودان ولكن انا يريد ان يجد مبررات
لحكمه الذي كان نحو العام 83 قد استنفذ
اغراضه بالتمام
حاول يجب مبررات لحكمه في ان يستخرج
البترول ولم يكن ذلك كافيا
فعملت الى
اعلان تطبيق الحدود
ليكون هذا الامر موصول بدرامه كبيره جدا
تمنح نظامه شرعيه وتمنحه كذلك اسباب جديده
للبقاء هو طبعا كانت في العامه من بعد 69
بعد انقلاب مايو
ووصول
النميري في ذكرى بدا الحديث على دستور في
السودان بين الدستور مدني ودستور اسلامي
صحيح نعم هو طبعا اصلا السياسه السودانيه
الوطنيه لم تكن تعرف هذه المباينه بين
سياسه اسلاميه وسياسه غير اسلاميه كانت
حركه وطنيه عاديه ولكن مساله الدستوره
الاسلامي والقوانين الاسلاميه كانت موجوده
اكثر من مكان في العالم الاسلامي وفي
العام 1947 قبل الاستقلال بسبعه اعوام
كانت هنالك جماعه تسمى نفسها الجماعه
الجماعه الدستوره الاسلامي
وهذه الجماعه كانت بعيده شيئا ما عن
الحركه الاسلاميه
ولكن في
كانوا ايش كانوا قوميين عرب ام ماذا كانوا
كانوا شيوخا كانوا شيوخا في المعهد العلمي
ويخرج الازهر بعض شيوخ الطرق الصوفيه
يلبون ويخاطبون الاشواق المعروفه عند عند
السودانيين وعند عامه المسلمين ان
المسلمين ينبغي ان يحكم بدستور اسلامي رغم
ان الترابي بخطابه للصحب جلال كشك قال انه
لم يكن يعلم ولا هو ولا اي من قاده جبهه
الميثاق لم يكونوا يعلمون ما هو الدستور
الاسلامي ولكن كان هذا شعار يخ الاشواق او
يخاطب احلام
ويخاطب بعض الرؤى التي تتوق الى مجد
الحضاره الاسلاميه بعد فتره الاستعمار
وكان هذا مفهوم في هذا السياق ولكن حضرتك
تقول انه الدكتور حسن ترابي يقول ان
الدستور الاسلام لم يكن يعني لم يعرفوا
كيف او ما هو الدستور الاسلامي في ذلك
الوقت رغم حملهم لهذا الشعار كحركه
اسلاميه نعم هو ذكر ذلك رغم انه عندما اسس
اعاده تاسيس الحركه الاسلاميه سماها جبهه
الميثاق الاسلامي لم يسميها جبهه الدستور
الاسلامي ولا جبهه القوانين لانه هو كان
اطروحته مقاربته لمساله الاسلام هي
الاسلام الشامل للحياه ان يجدد الاقتصاد
بالاسلام وان يجدد السياسه بالاسلام ويجدد
التعليم ويجدد الاعلام ويجدد الجهاد ويجدد
الجيش فالحياه كان يريد ان تتجدد باسم
الاسلام فلذلك مساله ان يكون دستور اسلامي
او قانون اسلامي او حدود اسلاميه هذه لم
تكن تسع فكرته ولكن عندما خاطب الصحفي
جلال كشك في مجله الحوادث جلال كشك ذكر ان
الترابي عندما دعي الى ابو ظبي ليكتب
الدستور وسئل عن الاسلامي الترابي ذكر انه
هذه صعبه يزول فالتراب يرد عليه قال له
انا كنت ومعي جماعه ندعو لدستور الاسلامي
في الستينات هذا الكلام طبعا كان بعد
الثوره الايرانيه نحو اخر السبعينات فقال
لم اكن انا ولا ايا من قاده الجبهه
الجبهه الميثاق الاسلامي نعلم ما هو
الدستور الاسلامي رغم ان الدكتور الترابي
هم متخصص في الفقه الدستوري المقارن وخريج
جامعه لندن وجامعه السربون ولكن مساله ان
يكون هنالك دستور اسلامي لدوله معاصره ولم
يكن يعلم ذلك
هذه نشرت في مجله الحوادث في العام 1999
ذكر التراب بانه لم يكن يعلم ولكنه الان
بعد ان قضى حوالي سبع سنوات في المعتقل
واعاد قراءه التراث الاسلامي
وعاد
مقارنته في القانون يمكن ان يساعد في
التعرف على شيء اسمه الدستور الاسلامي
لحتى الدستور الخمينيه فتحت الشهيه لهذا
الموضوع لاعاده بعثه من جديد هو طبعا
الطوق للمساله الدستوريه والقانونيه ليس
من من مقاربات الترابي الترابي يتوق الى
التجديد التام او يسميها اوبت الحياه
العامه الى الدين يريد الفن ان يعود كما
ذكرته يريد السياسه واريد ان يكون الدستور
جزءا من هذا التحول الكبير ولكن الثبت
طبعا بعد تجربته 30 عام في الحب استحاله
ان تحول اقتصاد المعاصر اقتصاد اسلامي او
حتى ان تحول الفنون المعاصره الى فنون
اسلاميه سببت استحاله التاصيل بهذا المعنى
ليس بالمعنى الذي عيناه المفكر لماذا في
العام 1977 بالتحديد جاء القرار بمراجعه
القوانين بالنسبه لنوميري
وتحالف مع الحركه الاسلاميه في ذلك الوقت
وكان رئيس القضاه انذاك خلف الله الرشيد
كان وصف هذا انه امتدادا للبعث الاسلامي
اللي دعا له النميري ليش تحديدا 77 هل
بسبب خلافاته مع الاحزاب
طبعا احنا نعرف انه ميري كان يساري يعني
وما ادري اذا كان ايضا يعني ينتمي للتيار
الشيوعي او القومي او الناصري
فهل الخلافات مع هذه الاطياف والانقسامات
في داخل التيار اليساري دفعت الى توظيف
موضوع التطبيق الشريعه وتطبيق الحدود
ام انه كان تدين يعني هو تدين وتبنى هذه
الفكره هنالك مرحلتين المرحله الاولى التي
اشرت اليها عام 77 وهي مساله سياسيه
بالتمام تسمى في السياسه السودانيه
المعاصره بالمصالحه الوطنيه كانت هنالك
احزاب يمينيه تقود معارضه ضد النميري
النميري تخلى عن الشيوعيه في العام
1971 او 1972 لسقوط انقلاب هاشم العطش
شيوعي واتجه السياسه السودانيه الخارجيه
اتجهت كلها الى المعسكر الغربي تعلمين ان
ذلك كان ايام الحرب البارده في هذا السياق
زلط الاحزاب اليمينيه تعارضه حتى بعد ان
قضى على الحزب الشيوعي وانقلب عليه لكن في
العام 77 قام النميري في بحثه عن اسباب
تجديد بقاء نظامه بلقاء خطير جدا في
السياسه السودانيه وهو مقابل الزعيم
المعارضه السيده الصادقه المهدي في بورسود
ثم اعلن عن ذلك ثم افرج عن المعتقلين
جميعا بما فيهم حسن الترابي للمناسبه
الجبهه الوطنيه كانت تضم جبهه الميثاق
الاسلامي وتضم الحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
بزعامه الشريف الهندي وتضم حزب الامه
بزعامه الامام الصادق المهدي كان لم يكن
امامنا
هذه الاحزاب الثلاثه صالحها النميري في
يوليو 1977 بعد عام واحد من حدث الغزول
الذي قامت به الجبهة الوطنيه قزت الخرطوم
في اثنين يوليو
76 ثم في عام 1977 صالحها النميري في عام
واحد تحولت السياسه السودانيه او سياسه
نظام جعفر النميري بالكامل وهذا كان معروف
طبعا عن طبيعه الصراعات السودانيه انها لا
تحتمل البقاء طويلا نجح للسلم اذا سالت
دماغها يجنح للسن فيجنح للسلم عام 77
وكان في محاوله منه ان يقدم هدايا لهذه
الجماعات السياسيه الجديده قدم لا صادق
المهدي هديه هي انه ستكون هنالك انتخابات
عامه في كل البلاد وعند اذن سيتاح للصادق
المهدي ان يترشحوا ان يكون رئيس وزراء
وقدم هديه للتيار الاسلامي بان كون له
لجنه مراجعه القوانين التي تتماشى مع
الشريعه الاسلاميه حتى في هذه المرحله
كانت الحركه الاسلاميه بقياده الترابي
تعلم انه التحول الفوري الثوري
للقانون السوداني يطبق الحدود ويحرم
الخمور ويخرج على السياقه العام في
العلاقات الدوليه كانت تعلم انه غير منقذ
ولذلك من اجتهادات الطريفه التي قدمها
الترابي للجنه ان الخمر ليس حدا بامكان ان
يشرب الخمر ان يعاقبه القاضي بالسجن واثار
هذا ضجه كبيره في اللجنه ولكنه هذا في
حياتها ام لا لا لا هذا في عام 1976 انت
تسالينني عن لجنه مراجعه القوانين التي
تتماشى مع الشريعه الاسلاميه هذه اللجنه
تكونت في تلك الفتره وفي تلك الفتره ظهرت
اجتهادات التراب التي نسميها تقدميا فانا
ذاك يعني فاعطى للقاضي خيار ان
يلجا الى
السجن بدلا من الجلد لان الجلد في في دون
ان يعبر عن ذلك لم يكن يناسب
الاعراف المعاصره في العقوبات او فلسفه
القانون العام المعاصر لم يكن ذلك مناسبا
فاعطى نظر الخيار وهذا اثار جدل هذه مرحله
مرحله مراجعه القوانين التي تتماشى مع
الشريعه الاسلاميه وذكرت لك ان الترابي
ذكر ان 10% فقط من قوانين السودان لم يكن
يريد ان يجعل من مساله القوانين دراما
للتحول الاسلامي ان يريد في السياق
المعروف الهادي البطيء العميق العلمي الذي
قامت عليه ليان ضخمه من كبار
اللي تغير في عام 83 بين 77 و83 طبعا بضع
اعوام في هذه الاعوام فقط ان ميريرات بقاء
نظامي
بالنسبه لموقف الترابي من موضوع تطبيق
الشريعه وتطبيق الحدود ايش اللي تغير هذه
الخمس سنوات هل هي البراجماتيه السياسيه
يعني تم استخدام موضوع تطبيق الشريعه
باغراض سياسيه هذا سؤال مهم الذي لجا
للشريعه بتلك الطريقه الدراميه هو النميري
وليس الترابي ولكن في تحالف كان بين تحالف
كبير ومهم واتولع عده مناصب في عهد وزير
عادل اتوقع كنت ساشرح لك ذلك الترابي كان
وزيرا للعدل الى حين تكوين اللجنه التي
عهد اليها
بمراجعه القوانين وانزال قوانين الحدود
اخذ الترابي من منصبه اعفي من منصب وزير
العدل والنائب العام وتحول الى مستشار الى
القصر وقام النميري بتاسيس لجنه من ثلاثه
قانونيين معروفين الشيخ النيل ابو قرون
ينتمي الى الجماعه دينيه كبيره
وزملائه بدريه سليمان هذه معروفه في
السيارات القانونيه
والاستاذ عوض الجيل وكان همه الكبير ان لا
ينسب هذا الفضل وهذه الدراما الضخمه لا
تنسب الى الحركه الاسلاميه فلذلك ابعده من
هذا المكان ولكن الحركه الاسلاميه كانت
تتوفر على برايماتيه كما ذكرتي فايدت
النيميري في ذلك
وفي مرحله كمان ثالثه هي مرحله ابريل 84
التي اعفى فيها النميري معظم مساعديه
وعاهد بكل الوظائف الكبيره الى الحركه
الاسلاميه فكان هذا التحول كان يبحث عن
اسباب لبقاء نظامه والترابي اعلم ان
التراب ان النميري سيؤدي له دورا مستحيل
ان تؤديه الحركه الاسلاميه هو تدمير
القوانين القائمه ولم يدمر فقط القانون
العقوبات ولكنه مثلا دمر قانون الضرائب
عندما اعلن عن قانون الزكاه بالطبع في
السودان في اكثر من 30 ضريبه اساسيه ان
تبدل فجاه بالزكاه دون ان يكون هنالك فقيه
واحد يعرف كيف يمكن للزكاه ان تطبق في
ظروف دوله معاصره بعد تعطيلها الف عام كان
هذا واضحا جدا انه سيحدث دمار كبير في
بنيه القانون هذا طبعا لم ناتي للدمار
السياسي عندما عدم الاستاذ محمود محمد طه
هذه نقطه بنجيلها الموضوع لكن
قوانين سبتمبر هل كتبها هل ساهم الترابي
في كتابتها ام كتب اخرون هذا مشهور جدا في
السياسه السودانيه ان الذين كتبوا قوانين
سبتمبر هم الشيخ النيل ابو قرون والاستاذه
بدريه سليمان والاستاذ عوض الجيد ثلاثه من
القوانين من القانونين هم الذين عينوا
مستشارين لرئيس الجمهوريه وجلسوا في القصر
والغريبه المفارقه انه
ثلاثتهم من تلاميذ الترابي ولكن
لا يقرب التراب بهذه المساله حتى عندما
كانوا يكتبون قانون الذكاء يواجهون مشاكل
كبيره في ذلك كانوا يلجاون الى التراب في
الامسيات سريرا يعني حتى لا تعلم به
لم يكن الترابي هو اللي يب ينحاز او يبعد
نفسه عن الصوره هذه بانها هو مؤيد لموضوع
تطبيق الحدود الشرعيه وهو كاتبها ومن
صاغها واشرف عليها وطبعا بالنسبه
للسودانيين ان كل تحول اسلامي قانوني
بالضروره سيرتبط بالتراب
شخصيه سياسيه ما قانونيه معنيه بالشريعه
وتدعو للشريعه منذ منتصف الستينات فلذلك
الامريكان واعيا لهذه المساله فاخذه بعيدا
الى القصر وعينهم مستشارا وعين هذه اللجنه
والشيخ النيله ابو قرون رغم انه وضح بصوره
كامله في كتابه الاسلام والدوله ان كلمه
حكم في الاسلام تعني الاحكام القضائيه ولا
تعني الحكم بالمعنى الذي تدعو له الحركات
الاسلاميه يعني الحكم الا لله
وكان يعلم انه مهمتهم كانت محصوره في هذه
الجانب هي مهمتهم هي ان يكتب قوانين
الحدود والنيميري نفسه اعلنها في ظهيره
نهار عندنا ساعه الذروه في الاستماع للاسر
السودانيه الساعه الثالثه ظهرا فالنبيري
القى خطاب الثالث ظهرا قال فيه اننا نظرنا
في كتاب الله ووجدنا الخمر محرمه ونظرنا
في القانون السوداني فوجدنا اوجدناه حلالا
ونظرنا في الزنا في كتاب الله وجدناه
محرما ونظرنا في قانون السودان فوجدناه
حلالا ونظرنا فعمل خطاب شكله نفسه درامي
جدا حتى يحفظ هذا الزخم لكن
السداد المحبوب احنا ايضا بالنسبه لموقف
الدكتور الترابي يعني هو
الجعفر النميري سياسي ويتولى السلطه في
ذلك الوقت بيبحث عن اي وسيله لتثبيت اركان
حكمه لكن موقف الترابي في موضوع تطبيق
الحدود الشرعيه
والاحتفاليه المسيره المليونيه التي نظمها
ودعا اليها عدد من الزعماء الاسلاميين هذه
لا تشير الى اعتراض انه الترابي على هذه
القوانين ولم يعترض هو ايدها بالكامل
ودعمها بالكامل وانا ذكرت لك في الاجابه
السابقه النميري قام بعمل كانوا يتمنون ان
يحدث وان يقوم شخص بازاله القوانين
القديمه التقليديه نقول لم تكن قديما ولم
تكن تقليديه لكن كان السودانيه
لا يعبئ بان يحطم ما امامه فحطم لهم
السياقه القانوني القائم وكانت كبير جدا
امامهم وان يملو هذا الفراق لا سيما انهم
لم يكونوا يتوفرون على القرار السياسي
القرار السياسي كان عند لجنه القصر
هنالك تاييد كامل من الحركه الاسلاميه
وتاييد تكتيك لانه في في في في خلف
[موسيقى]
ذهنهم ان اي تحول اسلامي في النهايه سيصب
لصالح الحركه الاسلاميه فلذلك
هم لم يؤيدوا القوانين فقط ولم يحتفلوا
بعد عام ثم كذلك قبلوا ان يؤدوا البيعه
للنميري وحاول التراب ان يتدخل في صيغه
البيعه التراب لم يكتب القوانين لكن كتب
صيغه البيعه صيغه البيعه التي كتبها
الترابي كانت تولزي النميري بالشورى
والعدل والاجتهاد في مصالح الامه وحاول
التراب ان يشرح معنى البيع لان جاء من عقد
البيع انك اذا اعطيت الوالي كل هذا يجب
الوالي ان يعطيك العدل وان يعطيك
النكهه في مصالح الامه وان يعطيك الشورى
فكانت هنالك
مفارقه ذهنيه ما نسميه الستيتو فماين بين
حاله الحركه الاسلاميه وحاله الترابي
التراب وحاله النميري النميري كما ذكرت
يريد ان يثبت اركان حكمه الحركه الاسلاميه
كانت تنظر للمستقبل انها يمكن اذا افسح
لها ازيحت من من الطريق عوائق القوانين
التقليديه فانها قادره على ان تثبت
قوانينها وهو ما حدث طبعا عند ائتلافه مع
الصادق المهدي وهو موضوع اظننا سناتي عليه
طيب اسالك
من ناحيه تنفيذ الاحكام هذه القطع وحد
الحرابه ايش تذكر لي بهذا من الجهات اللي
كانت معنيه حتى تنفذ هذه
الاحكام الحدود الشرعيه
هو طبعا
اعلان الحدود في سبتمبر ارتبط بازمه كبيره
في في نظام وهي ازمه النميري مع القضاه
القضاه اضربوا عن العمل وكانت مسائل
متعلقه اقلبها ليس بالاصلاح قانون
القوانين كانت مصلحه ولكن كانت متعلقه
باوضاعهم
المخصصات واوضاعهم المعيشيه فدخلوا مع
النمر في ازمه ضخمه وهو اراد ان يتجاوز
هذه الحاله المطلبيه وان يغمرهم كمان
بمساله جديده وهي مساله انه سيطبق الحدود
هذا لم يكن في خاطر القضاه الذين اطربه
كان صعبا جدا ان تنفذ حتى القطع
الاحتاج
الوزير العدل
انذاك السيد الرشيد السيد دفع الله الحاج
يوسف وهو احد قدامى الاسلاميين وهو رحمه
الله حاول ان يكتب مذكرات تفسيريه انه متى
يطبق حد القطع ولكن النيميرو كان يريد
الدراما كان يريد ان يسارع وان يتعجل ذلك
طبيب جراح مشهور وتم تدريبه على القطع
ووقع القطع في سجل كوبر في احتفال جماهير
كبير ثم كسرت الخمور كذلك حطمت القوارير
الخمر في على شاطئ النيل فالدراما كلها
كانت مقصوده
وكذلك بعضهم كان يعتقد ان هنالك تحولا
كبيرا قد حدث ان فعلا السودان قد ابى الى
الاسلام
وكان يسميه طبعا
تور منصور خالد نسميه العهد الغيهب العهد
الذي انتهت في السياسه السودانيه وتحولت
الى حال الشعوذه
في خطب النميري بدعم من الحركه الاسلاميه
في السودان صحيح
نعم
تحولت الى غياهب التاريخ او يعني الى واقع
مظلم بدعم ايضا وتاييد ونصره الحركه
الاسلاميه هو للمفارقه الحركه الاسلاميه
كانت تتوفر على طاقم القياده اغلب او لم
يكن كله قد درس في الغرب وعلى معرفه كبيره
بالسياسه الغربيه
وكان يدير سياسه
تقليديه تقريبا يعني
تحتاج ان افحصها جيدا لتعرف اين الاسلام
في هذه المواقف وكان واضح انهم جماعه
السياسيه
بتحولات اجتماعيه
تدين وسط الشباب وسط الشابات او كذا ولكن
لم يكن
الموضوع على الحركه الاسلاميه هو تطبيق
الحدود هذه المساله في سياقها التاريخي هو
كان بحث النميري عن مبررات لاسباب
لكن استاذي فاضل موضوع تطبيق الحدود
الشرعيه او تطبيق الشريعه هو هذا الشعار
يعني الرئيسي لدى الحركه الاسلاميه سواء
في السودان وغير السودان يعني الاسلام هو
الحل تطبيق الشريعه الاسلاميه تطبيق
الحدود الشرعيه يعني هذه هي زبده ما تحاول
الحركه الاسلاميه ان تميز بين خطابها او
مشروعها وما بين
التيارات الاخرى بغرض الوصول الحكم لكن
ندخل بنقاش هذا السر لكن ودي اسالك موضوع
المسيره المليونيه واللي لو تحكي لي
تفاصيل عن هذا كيف الدور اللي لعبه
الدكتور الترابي في شحذ زخم لقانون تطبيق
الشريعه من خلال مسيره المليونيه ومن اتى
من
الدعاه من دول عربيه واسلاميه في ذلك
الوقت نعم
يواجه معارضه ضخمه من من طاقمه من خاصته
من وزراه من مستشاريه
وكذلك واجه مقاومه من الاقليم الدول
الاقليم كلها سواء كانت مصر والمملكه
السعوديه
وفضلا عن الغرب مثلا امريكا وبريطانيا
وهنالك مشكله كبيره في السودان لسه مشكله
الجنوب حلت لتوها بعد 73 فان ميل قضاء
سنين جيده من 73 الى 83 في سلام مع الجنوب
فكان واضح ان هذا الامر سيعيد السوداني
للحرب الاهليه
فلذلك النمر كان
يريد من الاسلاميين ان يبدو له دعما في
اللحظه التي تركه فيها اعوانه وزملائه
السابقين
فاغلب الاعداد للمسيره المليونيه تم
بواسطه الحركه الاسلاميه وحشد ضخم جدا
عاد فيه سمير غراسلو وتعادوا الى جذور
المجتمع الى الطرق الصوفيه الى القبائل
هذه مناطق تعرفها الحركه الاسلاميه اكثر
مما يعرفها مثلا الحزب الحاكم الاتحاد
الاشتراكي
فحشدوا وكان الحشد مهولا وكان ملفتا وكان
مخيفا حتى بالنسبه للنميري انه يبدو ان
هنالك تحول كبير فعلا في مسار ثوره مايو
قد تحولت بالفعل لانه كل هذه الملايين قد
خرجت الى الشارع
فهذا من ناحيه كان تعبير عن مقدره الحركه
الاسلاميه على الحشد ومن ناحيه كذلك تنبيه
الى
الخطر الذي يمكن ان ياتي منها
نعم بالضبط بالضبط
هل هو لم يلبث طبعا حتى زاره نائب الرئيس
جورج
وقام في اليوم التالي باعتقال قاده الحركه
الاسلاميه وايداعهم من راس الدوله من
مساعد رئيس الجمهوريه الى سجن كوبر طيب
في فتره وجيزه جدا طبقت طبقت عشرات الحدود
يعني يمكن باكثر مما طبقت في كل التاريخ
الاسلامي
فهذا احدث صدمه طبعا حتى بالنسبه
للمعتاد الاجرام انذاك كانوا يتصورون ان
النميري انما
[موسيقى]
يقوم بلعبه سياسيه كما اعتادوا عليه ولكن
ان يؤخذوا ان تقطع ايديهم وكذا وكذا لم
يحدث تحول فقط قانوني ولكن احدث تحول حتى
اجتماعي فطبقت الحضور وبكثافه وبقسوه خاصه
في مرحله ثالثه اشرت اليها بعد ابريل لان
ميريكان يريد دراما اكثر ويريد عنف اكثر
ويريد ارهاب اكثر
فقطعت ايادي صلب
بعض
المدانين في المحاكم المحاكم نفسها اصبح
اسمها محاكم العداله الناجزه هذا المصطلح
ظهر مع لجنه مراجعه القوانين ومع ازمه
القضاه ان الترابي كان يريد ان يتجاوز ما
يسميه بمطل القضاء ان القضيه تاخذ وقت
طويل جدا فيريد للعداله ان تكون ناجزه
فالنجاز هذه لم تتحول الى نجازه فعلا في
تطبيق القانون ولكن في كثافه الدراما
المتعلقه بتطبيق الاحكام
هذا جزء من المشهد الذي اشرنا اليه ان
نحول السياسه السودانيه الى حاله من الهوس
والشعوذه طيب هل هذه الاحكام ايضا طبقت
على النساء
بالطبع
لا لم اسمع ان امراه سرقت وثبت عليها لكن
طبق عليها حد الخمر مثلا لانه حد الزنا
وحد الزنا نعم طبق تنفيذ الرجم حد الزنا
لم لم ينفذ اي حد للرجل لانه عندما بدات
الاحكام في هذه المرحله
تاخذ هذا الشكل الخطير بدا النيميري
يستشعر ان هنالك خطر على الكرسي الذي يجلس
عليه وانا ذكرت لك ان الماء سياسيه
بالتمام عندما تجعل النيميري ان هنالك
مفارقه بين ان يبقى في الكرسي وانطبق
الحدود
ضحى بالحدود يعني عطل هذه المسائل يعني لم
نشهد في الخرطوم ولا في السوابق القانونيه
السودانيه حاله الرجم بعد ذلك طبعا في
قانون 91
او في في
ليس في الرقمي فقط حتى في الخمر حتى في
القطع هنالك كثير من الحيل وكثير من
التحوطات وكثير من الاجراءات التي تمنع
تطبيق الحدود يعني بدلا
وبعد وصول يعني عمر البشير والمؤتمر
الشعبي كانت تنفذ الحدود طبقت حمرات
محدوده جدا لكن واقعه الامر انه عندما
ذهبوا الى المفاوضات السلام مع الجنوب
وكانت الحركه الشعبيه بقياده تصير على
انها لا يمكن ان تصالح نظام يطبق قوانين
مستمده من من دين بعض الشعب لانه هذا
بمبدا المساواه امام القانون هذا في عهد
الصادق المهدي صحيح بعد سقوط بعد انقلاب
على النميري نفسه لا انت اشرت ل91 هذا في
عهد في عهد الانقاذ طبقت الحدود بمحدوديه
شديده جدا لانه كانوا يخشون الراي العام
العالمي والمحلي وكانوا يعلمون ردود
الافعال فلذلك انا دائما ما اشير الى انه
حركه اسلاميه الحركه السودانيه كان ينبغي
ان تكون مقاربتها لمساله الاسلامي مختلفه
ان تعلم ان القانون الاسلامي يمضي مع
سياقات القانون العام القانون العام
للكثابتا تغييرا لان المجتمعات متغيره
الاحكام الاحكام التي جاءت في القران كلها
جاءت في سياقات تاريخيه وصرفيه ما من حكم
من احكام الاسلام الا وله اصل في اعراف
الجاهليه في التوراه في قانون حمروبي
لا بد ان يكون له اصل القران لم يبدع حكما
هنا ان تكون له اصول فكان هو تعديل
للاوضاع وكانت تدرجا كان ينبغي ان نصل الى
نتيجه انه الاحكام وسياقاتها التاريخيه هي
التي تحكمها وان القانون يتماشى مع
القانون العامل متغير لان المجتمع متغير
السبب اسالك لو هل كان يعني تنتهيئه اطباء
ام هو طبيب واحد
لتنفيذ
الاحكام القطع او كانت هل فقط في الخرطوم
ام كان في تنفيذ في ولايات ومدن اخرى في
السودان وكان يحتاج طبعا لطبيب واحد يدرب
الاخرين على الطبيب لا يحتاج ان يقوم
بالعمليه هذه يقوم بها من هم دونه في
الحقل الطبي
هذا الطبيب درب بعض الناس وهم دربوا بعض
الناس في الولايات فنفذت احكام القطع بهذه
الطريقه التي حاولت ان تكون رفيق لكن في
النهايه ان الشخص يفقد يده كما ذكر
الدكتورا في نقاشه مع عثمان انه لا يريد
ان يقطع يد مواطنه لانه يريد لمواطنه ان
يعود ويعمل من جديد لا يريد ان يجعله
مدى الحياه كما كان في الاعراف التوراتيه
من تم تنفيذ احكام الخطا ايش موقعهم اليوم
ايش مصيرهم اليوم وذلك الوقت يعني من خلال
مشاهداتك هم كونوا جماعه اشبه بالرابطه او
النقابه و يتواصلون
واظلوا يتواصلون كذلك مع المنظمات الدوليه
وظلوا يطالبون
برد الاعتبار وبعاده الحقوق وهذا كان
الفتره الديمقراطيه الثالثه من
هي طبعا من 85 الى 89
وحتى بعد الانقاذ واصلوا كذلك ولكن لم يكن
المناخ العام يسمح لهم مطال
بهم
طبعا طبعا اطراف صناعيه تعويض مادي تعويض
معنوي
كانوا من اخذ على حين غره وهم اغلبهم
بسيطين يعني اقول لهم من اكبر العوار في
هذه القوانين انها لا تقطع اليد في الحق
العام في اذا اخذت ماء العام اذا اختلست
الملايين من الشركه او من الوزاره التي
تعملين فيها لا تقطع اليد لان هنالك شبهه
ان لك حق في هذا المال فالفساد الذي يدور
في العالم كله ويدور في المال العام لا
تعني هذا القوانين قوانين خارج سياق
التاريخ بالكامل
القطع يقع على
الجناه
بسيطين لم ينالوا الحظ من العلم ولا تدريب
فيما يتعلق بالجهه القضائيه التي تصدر
الاحكام القضائيه هذه
هل كانوا من نفس جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين اللي كانتوقع الاحكام
تطبيق الحدود الشرعيه
انا اشرت الى ان هنالك محاكم تاسست اسمها
محاكم العداله الناجزه
وهذه المحاكم كان فيها عدد من افراد
الحركه الاسلاميه القضاه وكان في عدد من
رموز الطرق الصوفيه المعروفه
ومحاكم العداله الناجزه هذه هي حدث فيها
اكبر فوضى قانونيه ممكنه لذلك ايما قانوني
محترم قبل ما يكون يستطيع ان يواصل مثلا
حافظ الشيخ الزاكي عميد كليه القانون ومن
كبار اسلامي استقل من منصب قاضي الاستئناف
الاعلى
الاستئناف دفعنا الحاج يوسف وزير العدل
نفسه رئيس القضاء معذره رئيس القضاء نفسه
كان معترضا وترك هذه التحول في ابريل انه
تطبيق القوانين عبر المحاكم العداله
الناجزه كان في فوضى كانت هنالك كذلك فوضى
اخرى متعلقه ما يسمى القانون الشروع في
الزنا
رجل امراه يتم القبض عليهما في شوارع
الخرطوم
يطبق عليه هذا القانون ان هناك شبهه شروح
في الزنا وكان اغلب الاسر التي تحتاج ان
تخرج
تزود نفسها بوثيقه الزواج
القسيم ايوه تزود نفسها بهذه الوثيقه فلا
يسمح لك بالتنزه مع زوجتك لانك انت معرض
لان فكانت هنالك فوضى بالفعل في
مرحوبه في اشباه الزينه مثلا هذه اذا كان
اثنين ماشيين نفسها الرجل
وتكتب الاسماء في الصحف
فكان هذا البعض من الدراما لكن يقع على
الاسر والاسماء وكان هذه حاله من التشهير
فكانت فكان كان كان هذا اسوا ما في الامر
طيب استاذي طبعا هو قوانين سبتمبر
اسمها ليش وصفت بهذا هل هذه يعني
اطلقت عليها من ناحيه الانقاص من قبل
تيارات اخرى اما لها اسم اخر هو طبعا صدرت
في شهر سبتمبر ولكن المعارضه هي التي
اطلقت عليها هذا الاسم لكي لا تنسبها
للاسلام اسمتها قوانين سبتمبر حتى لا تنسب
للاسلام
والنظام قوانين الشريعه الاسلاميه
والمعارضه
بعد سنوات تنصه للترابي من قوانين تطبيق
الشريعه ودوره فيها وقال لو كان بيكتب
فحتما ستكون افضل من هذه القوانين
الموجوده رغم انه هو كان المشرف لهذه
القوانين وهو حتى الكثير من يرى هو منظرها
وهو راعيها هو طبعا هذا الكلام هو الذي
ذكره الامام الصادق المهدي عندما كان رئيس
الوزراء انه قوانين نيميري عدت على عجل
والاسباب سياسيه ولكننا نظرنا بعمق الى
هذه القوانين هذه العمق لا لم يحل الاشكال
لا هو الترابي قال قال يعني لو
كنا قوانين لكنت كتبت افضل منها
يعني ان بعد بعد ما صار يفصح بمعارضه
لموضوع تطبيق الحدود القطع واحد الحرابه
طبعا بعد ذلك هو وقع كما ذكرت انت اتفاقيه
مع الحركه الشعبيه في في
العامه 2001 مع الحركه الشعبيه ثم اتفاقيه
اخرى 2001
في 2003 ايدت اتجاه الحركه الشعبيه الى
ايجاد جيب اداري منطقه اداريه تستثنى فيها
فيها المواطنين من احكام الشريعه
الاسلاميه حتى يستطيع الجنوبيين ان
يشعروا انهم مواطنين اذا كنت مسيحي او
مسلم تشعر في هذه المعاصمتك وانها تمثل
هذا كان يسميه الله استاذ محمود محمد طه
الاجبارات او اكراهات العصر انه
الصرف السياسي والظرفه المعاصر دائما يضعك
في كراهات ويتطرق للبحث عن الحيل وايجاد
بعض
التوازنات في الموقف السياسي يعني انت
تشوف تملصه
يبعد نفسه يحيد نفسه الترابي من كتابه هذه
القوانين قوانين سبتمبر جاءت يعني لهذا
السبب لسبب سياسي يعني انه اليوم ولم
يكتبوها ابدا ولم يكتبها ولكن يؤيدها
جوهريا الامر ليس اشرف عليها هو كان رئيس
اللجنه التنفيذيه يا استاذ السؤال اختي
الكريمه هو ليس تاييد القوانين او كتابتها
ولكن ما هو موقف الجوهري موقف الجوهري هو
انه يؤيد تطبيق الشريعه الاسلاميه في دوله
معاصره بهذا المعنى
وهذا يضع في مفارقه ومعارضه تماما مع
حوضوه المواطن المتساويه التي كان ينشدها
الجنوب والذي ادت الى وهذا الموقف لا
يتبناه كل الحركه الاسلاميه لانه الترابي
ترك الحكم في عام 2000 ولكنهم في عام 2005
عندما ذهبوا الى التفاوض لم يستطيعوا
التخلص من هذه الناحيه طب استاذ الى اليوم
يعني انا من عده ايام قليله
ظهر خبر يعني بحكم قضائي على تطبيق
بادانه ثلاث شبان
بينفذ فيهم حكم القطع يعني وحتى في فتره
الربيع
عاد هذا القانون الى المشهد من جديد كيف
توصف لي هذا القانون اليوم في السودان
هو القانون ما يزال ساريا صحيح انه
مثلا حد السرقه يحكم ولكن لا يطبق هناك
حدود اخطر من ذلك حتى الرجم من اشهر
حمله كبيره من قبل المنظمات النسائيه لان
هنالك بنت صغيره في في العشرين من عمرها
متطور وليس ثابت لانه المجتمعات متطوره
وليست ثابته هذا السؤال لم تستطيع الحركات
الاسلاميه الداعيه الى تطبيق الشريعه
الاسلاميه ان تجيب عليه
الدكتور على الحدود
ونام مع حضر اول حادث لقطع اليد وكان
مشهورا واغمي عليه في في تلك الحادثه
الاول تطبيق ترى في في ساحه سجن كوبر وكان
النميري وكل وزرائي حاضرين لم يتحمل منظر
الدماء ر انه ايد تطبيق الحدود او تعلمين
انه هنالك نسبه كبيره من البشر
منظر الدم يؤدي الى الاغماء فهو من هذه من
هذه الفئه يعني بعد الاغماء طبعا استمر هو
يعني مؤيد لتطبيق الحدود الشرعيه
وقبل هذا اليقظه ان استمر في طبعا طبعا
طب اسمح لي الله يسلمك استاذ محبوب احنا
نوقف حديثنا الى هنا في هذا الجزء الاول
ونتابع باقي المحاور وباقي نقاط وبنود
قوانين سبتمبر لشملت ايضا اضافه تطبيق
الشريعه كان موضوع الجهاد وموضوع الزكاه
وكان ايضا هناك نظام الامر بالمعروف
والنهي عن المنكر والتحولات اللي صارت في
هذا القانون يعني ما بين يعني تاره يتم
تصعيدها سياسيا وتاره اخرى يتم
مثل ما نقول تهدئته وعدم تفضل تجميل
يعطيك الف عافيه استاذ
[موسيقى]